this is actually the lead ship of flight
19. wow the exact same plane as this is
flight 19. yes
the final words of the men on flight 19
have been studied and poured over
every sentence and word analyzed in
depth by the navy's after action report
and then of course reanalyzed by
armchair historians and hacky cursed tv
shows
walk me through what happened to flight
19 what's the deal it was a training
flight for navigation training believe
it or not so we just got back from the
sapono which we we dove on that was
their target so we know they dropped
their bombs on the sapona right what was
their path after that due east to east
for another 60 70 miles okay then make a
turn to the north northwest what
happened it's a big mystery to this day
right nobody knows exactly what happened
to him
nobody knows but there are theories
colleen sterling is the lebron james of
aviation probability analysis you maybe
didn't know there wasn't lebron james of
that after two years of searching for
air france flight 447 colleen was
brought in as part of a small team to
reanalyze the data they found the
wreckage in less than five days
the first thing we did is looked at the
500 page navy report that came out the
communications all the radar hits that
they had and we wrote a chronology the
key transmissions
everything is map-based right so i'll
put like where they launched from and
the time and then i'll draw the line
where they were supposed to go and then
i can calculate with the wind and
they're heading how long it should have
taken them to get to their first turn
point
i thought about that first turn point
and then i said well where could they
have gone from there they were trying to
go back to the northwest but the wind
was blowing them and they may have not
made the turn sharp enough and might
have got significantly blown to a
different heading
towers
what is your compass reading powers
i don't know where we are
must have gotten lost after that last
turn
mt-28 this is ft-74 what is your trouble
uh both my compasses are out and i'm
trying to find fort lauderdale florida
so this is the compass here that's the
magnetic that's the magnetic compass so
he would be looking at this what else
would he look at that and then hit down
on his instrument panel you have what's
called the gyro compass here that you
set this with this knob to agree with
this to agree with this bounces around
sure that one is very stable
taylor who's the flight lead was talking
about the compass didn't look right he
started to get confused but they know
they have to get back taylor thought
that they needed to fly to the northeast
because he thought they were over the
florida keys
how did you think it's very hard to
imagine him getting that lost he doesn't
seem to have his wits about him on this
flight then you hear them arguing on the
radio it's really sad but
we've just passed over a small island
and we have no other land in sight
turn on your emergency isf gear or do
you have it on
iff gear was off i'm turning it on now
what's the isf gear iffs an acronym for
identification friend or folk okay right
here for example see this says 1200 in
an iff they would have given him a code
to squawk to put put in there and they
would be picked up on their radar he
didn't have it all he didn't have it on
should he have had it on especially if i
want help than finding out where i am
right
ft28 and now
iii one of the planes in the flight
thinks if we went 270 degrees we could
hit land
270 that's too late somebody with a
decent compass or somebody else is like
hey we just go 270 we're gonna hit last
time to get to their bombing target they
flew due east right well just flight due
to take it back
right we'll hit land at some point
ft 28 all planes in flight change course
to 0.90 for one minute
so now they're going back east again
powers who is the ranking guy on the
flight
he kept saying we need to go west right
and then it gets corroborated without
radar track that came from the solomon's
aircraft carrier and where did that see
them the radar track showed aircraft
going south
over land
there's a good chance that it could be
somewhere in this mid-peninsula east
coast of florida region so that wouldn't
surprise you at all no uh the the model
supports that
wow
we are now flying 270 degrees we will
fly 270 degrees until we hit the beach
or run out of gas
and now they know they're in trouble
because it's like time they're going to
run out of gas and they just don't have
a clue where they are
when the first plane drops below 10
gallons we all go down together
everyone understand that
[Music]
you